I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality exactly
do you remember that internship that I
applied for what about it it's in New
York New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you
sorry I'm a little out of practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I'm here to see Miko
[Music]
anger depression your weird self-hatred
you could benefit from a little
self-hatred
interesting I know you're going to want
to blame this on society or on your race
or whatever but this really is just
about you this is your rock bottom
what is she doing with that guy they're
being adorable
so we we finally get to meet your
mysterious boyfriend
hello Ben hi Praise Jesus maybe just be
honest with him
[Music]